from Carrie Underwood revealing the sex
of her second baby the Garth Brooks and
Keith Urban shedding some tears et's
taking a look at the standout moments
from the 2018 CMA Awards I just love
getting to do this ten years ago today I
moved to Nashville Kacey Musgraves won
Album of the year in a category of all
men she opened up to ET backstage
shortly after her win
how you feeling holding this right now
it's crazy this is awesome I really I
didn't expect to get that and it's a
really big honor so you said in your
speech that ten years ago you know you
had moved to national and here you are
winning a CMA does that still feel like
really surreal I cannot believe this
morning when I looked on it was on my
timeline thing ten years ago seriously
to the day like what crazy universe like
a little nod from the universe like
that's so wild so much has happened in
ten years I have a lot of people that
are responsible for helping me along and
I'm just really really grateful Florida
Georgia line and bebe Rexha rocked the
stage performing their record-breaking
smash hit meant to be
[Music]
while Garth Brooks performed his
touching new song stronger than me for
the first time which was dedicated to
his wife Trisha Yearwood and brought
them both to tears I breathe God takes
me first cuz you're strong
[Music]
and I'm sure people think oh we probably
sang a portion I've not heard this thing
and I I swear it I swear I'm asking a
please okay et spoke with Garza
backstage after the emotional moment I
did not cry Patricia I was stoic no I
saw their cheers Garth
you cried Richard and he kiss your face
beautiful very much Keith Urban and his
wife Nicole Kidman burst into tears
after he won the coveted Entertainer of
the Year honor
[Applause]
thank you so much
baby girl I love you so much thank you I
had this unstuck beyond shocked our
girls at home thief and munchkin I love
you thank you for supporting daddy and
loving me through all of what I do is
saying with you'd like to go and make it
all worthwhile in deeds he was with him
backstage after the wind I've been here
when people have announced Entertainer
of the Year so many years but there was
just something even bigger about it like
it was just everybody was like that's
right that's the right choice oh that's
nice that's do you feel that I was I was
I was just I did a lot of million things
going through my head just incredible
gratitude wishing my dad could have seen
it you know passed away a couple years
ago but I sort of could feel him as well
so you can feel his presence very much
yeah if you're Keith Urban's named
Entertainer of the Year
that's cousin Awards only as good as the
other people on that thing that man's
hell of an entertainment and a hell of a
fridge so good for him he deserves it
just wait docto Keith Urban you cried
for Tricia and you cried for him
[Music]
you